السلام عليكم ورحمه الله اهلا بكم
مشاهدينا في هذا العرض الاخباري الموجز
نقدمه لكم من الجزيره فاذا مرشحوا تحالف
الجمهور الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان
بولايه الرئاسيه جديده بعد جوله ثانيه
لانتخابات الرئاسه تقدم فيها على زعيم حزب
الشعب الجمهوري كملك الجدار اوغلو في
الدور الثاني من الانتخابات الرئاسيه وقد
حصل اردوغان على
52.16% من الاصوات مقابل
47.84 حصل عليها كالجدار اوغلو وذلك وفق
نتائج رسميه اوليه بعد تعزيز اصواته
فلاندول وشمال تركيا وتراجع اصوات منافسه
في مناطق الغالبيه الكرديه واكد الرئيس
التركي تعزيز تحالفه في المرحله المقبله
التي اشار الى انها ستكون تحت شعار مئويه
تركيا وقد ظهر على شرفه القصر الجمهوري مع
ابرز اعضاء تحالف الجمهور و بينهما المرشح
في الدوري الاول سنان اوغان
وفي خطابه امام مئات الالاف من انصاره قال
الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان انه ترك
الخلافه والنزاعات السياسيه وراى ظهره
وقال انه يدعو الى الوحده والتضامن
نحن بمقتدى المسؤوليه التي نتحملها بناء
على اراده الشعب لسنا غاضبين من احد وقد
تركنا الخلافات والنزاعات السياسيه التي
ظهرت خلال الحملات الانتخابيه جانبا
ونعتبر ان هذا وقت التوحد والتضامن وهذه
ليست مجرد شعارات بل انها كلمات صادره من
صميم قلبنا ونحن نعلم اننا نمثل الشعب
وقد تلقى الرئيس التركي اردوغان التهانيه
من الرئيسين الامريكي والروسي وقضت في دول
عده والامين العام للامم المتحده بعد
اعاده انتخابه رئيسا لتركيا كما اكد
الاتحاد الاوروبي والنيتو على العمل
المشترك مع انخرف في المرحله المقبله في
القضايا المشتركه
[موسيقى]
من جهته قال كمال مرشح المعارضه في
الانتخابات الرئاسيه انه يشعر بالحزن لان
هناك ما وصفه بمضايقات تنتظر بلاده واضاف
انه في هذه الانتخابات تجلت اراده الشعب
في التغيير مشيرا الى انه سيستمر في
النضال لاحلال الديمقراطيه على حد تعبيره
حق نزل ينمثناء
ما كان بالامكان ان اتغاضى عن انتهاك
حقوقكم وما كان بوسعي ان اسكت عن النظام
غير العادل وما كان بوسعي ان اتغاضى عن
الامكم امام تمتع اعداد كبيره من اللاجئين
بامتيازات الان اطلب منكم ان لا تترددوا
في الدفاع عن الديمقراطيه وقد راينا عمليه
انتخابيه غير عادله في المرحله الاخيره
فقد تم تجميع كل الامكانيات لصالح شخص
واحد
فالاثناء قدمت زعيمه حزب الجيد ميرال
لاكشنار تهانيها للرئيس التركي اردوغان
وقالت لنا تركيا عانت كثيرا بسبب
الاستقطاب وان الوقت هو وقت الاتحاد من
اجل حل هذه المشاكل
الاقوى بالنسبه الينا ولا اراده اعلى من
اراده الشعب هذه الانتخابات اظهرت اراده
الشعب التركي الذي اوصل رسائله عبرها
وواجبونك حزب ان نعمل بما تقتضيه هذه
الرساله بصفه معده جامعيه سابقه ادرك ان
كل شيء قابل للنقاش كل فكر او عمل قابل
للنقل او الاعتراض لكن الامر الوحيد الذي
لا يمكن الاعتراض عليه او مناقشته هي
نتائج الانتخابات نابعه من الاراده الحره
للناخب نقدم تهانينا للسيد رجب طيب
اردوغان الذي اعيد انتخابه بحسب نتائج
المؤقته حرام صارل وكان رئيس الهيئه
العليا للانتخابات التركيه احمد ينار اعلن
فوز الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان بولايه رئيسيه
بولايه الرئاسيه جديده وقال ان النتائج
شبه النهائيه اظهرت حصول اردوغان على 52%
من اجمالي الاصوات فيما حصل كمال
على ثمانيه واربعين في المئه تركيا
جمهوريه
نرى بان الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان تم
انتخابه رئيسا للجمهوريه مره اخرى ونحن
نتقدم بجزيل الشكر للناخبين الذين شاركوا
بحس سليم واننا نشكر جميع اعضاء الهيئه
العليا للانتخابات وممثلي الاحزاب وكلما
ساهم من الوزارات والمديريات والمؤسسات
وقوات الامن ولكل من تابع الانتخابات
نتقدم اليهم جميعا بالشكر
كما نشكر الاعلاميين الذين تابعوا
الانتخابات من البدايه الى النهايه واتمنى
ان تعود نتائج الانتخابات بالخير على
الديمقراطيه التركيه وعلى الشعب التركي
قلت الوساطه السعوديه الامريكيه الميسره
للتفاوض بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع في
السودان بمدينه جده قالت لنا الطرفين لم
يلتزما بالهدنه قصيره المدى التي وقعت
الاسبوع الماضي وذكرت الوساطه في بيان ان
كل طرف ارتكب خلوقا شملت استخدام الجيش
السوداني الطيران الحربي بشكل يومي
واحتلال الدعم السريع مرافق مدنيه ونشرت
تعزيزات عسكريه بجسر حلفايه استعدادا
لمهاجمه منطقه وادي سيدنا العسكريه ورصدت
الوساطه انتهاكات من قبل الطرفين عاقت
بشكل كبير لصلاه المساعدات الانسانيه
واستعاده الخدمات الانساسيه الاساسيه بعد
خمسه ايام من بدء الهدنه قصيره الامد
وطالبت الاطراف بالعمليه على تمديد الهدنه
لايصال مواد الاغاثه كما حثت الوساطه
الطرفين على الموافقه على تمديد وقف اطلاق
النار الحالي وان لم يتم التقيد به بشكل
كامل لتوفير مزيد من الوقت للجهات الفاعله
الانسانيه للاطلاع بهذا العمل الحيوي
ومع احتدام المعارك غربيه السودان قال
حاكم اقليم دارفور مني اركم الناوي ان
الاعتداءات على المواطنين نتضاعفت ملتهما
جهات لم يسميها بالتفريط في سلامه وحقوق
المواطنين وتخريب المؤسسات القوميه عمدا
ودعم الناوي سكان الاقليم بمختلف فئاتهم
الى حمل السلاح لحمايه ممتلكاتهم مؤكدا ان
ما سماها حركات الكفاح ستساندهم
في الولايات المتحده على النار رئيس جو
بايدن التوصل الى اتفاق بين الديمقراطيين
والجمهوريين بشان رفعي سقف الدين العام
دون الكشف عن طبيعه الصفقه وحتى بين
الكونجرس على تسريع اقراره
اتفقت مع رئيس مجلس النواب وتحدثنا في
مساله الموازنه ونحن مستعدون للتوجه الى
الكونجرس والاتفاق في الحقيقه توافق لا
يحقق لاي طرف مبتغاه كاملا فهو يجنب
البلاد اسوا ازمه ويحمي اولوياتها كما
يحمي منظومه التامين الصحي والمعاشات
وانني احط غرفه على تمريره
الفلسطينيه افدت مراسلته الجزيره باصابه
اربعه شبان فلسطينيين برصاص قوات الاحتلال
خلال اقتحامها مدينه جنين وشن عمليه
عسكريه في المدينه وفي اطراف المخيم
القريبه منها وتتصدموا قاومون فلسطينيون
للقوه المتواغله في احياء عده
انتهى العرض الاخباري الموجز اشكركم على
متابعته لما كنتم اوقاتكم بكل خير
[موسيقى]